Big shout out to the New York Knicks.
It's playoff time, baby.
Right now I’m about to salute
some of the great players from the Knicks.
From the past and the present.
Restoring the feeling in the city.
Let's go Knicks.
Pay close attention.
Julius Randle, respect he deserving.
Last Julius we seen this good
was Julius Erving.
Barrett been on his toes.
Give him his flowers while he's alive.
Somebody bring Derrick a rose.
Carmelo Anthony, that boy had a gift.
And J.R. used to be shooting
like he had a Smith.
Allan aint from Houston, but he shot
like a rocket.
When Anthony brought his mace in,
the competition got blinded.
Bernard was a king.
So was Larry Johnson.
John Starks dunked on Jordan in the Garden.
Willis Reed the defense repeatedly.
Patrick Ewing back you down
in the post, that was Patrick.
I say Frazier.
I ain't talking Joe the boxer.
Walt Frazier, the legendary Knickerbocker.
Earl “The Pearl” Monroe,
his game was timeless.
Stephon Marbury was
Coney Island's finest.
Amare was a star they admired.
Mark Jackson and Oakley
was on fire.
Then Quickley against Sprewell
will get choked quick.
I've got three words for you.
Let’s go Knicks.
Salute William Wesley.
What he doing, I like it.
Stephen A. Smith predicted it,
he's a psychic.
We here now. New York never quit.
I've got three words for you.
Let’s go Knicks.
Let's go Knicks.